le festival de cannes est forcément une
vitrine exceptionnelle pour les marques
chaque année elles sont plus d'une
vingtaine à s'installer sur la croisette
pour profiter du rayonnement de
l'événement il y a les couturiers lé
joaillier qui se battent pour habiller
les stars et les grandes marques
alimentaires qui accueille les people
les journalistes et les festivaliers sur
des plages ou lors de soirées privées
david aime faire est un jeu ni mon teint
et l'affairé lui le bon filon pour faire
connaître sa société de voiture avec
chauffeur à cannes pendant le festival
faire appel aux services d'une voiture
avec chauffeur n'a rien d'exceptionnel
bonjour luxe et l'élégance rapidement je
vous en prie installer vos cannes ses
palmiers ses stars c'est palace pendant
dix jours l'atmosphère est incomparable
c'est très intéressant de voir cannes
brouillé comme ça de deux personnalités
de gens c'est le quotidien de david aime
faire son métier chauffeur privé
ce génie montant de 28 ans a quitté la
région parisienne où ils travaillent
habituellement pour venir vivre le
festival de l'intérieur c'est pour une
expérience parce que paris c'est très
calme avec les ponts du mois de mai
parce que quitte est dans des bouchons
autant être vu que l'opportunité se
proposait dans des bouchons sur le bord
de mer et pour gagner de l'argent c'est
c'est calme à paris ça bouge beaucoup
pendant le festival donc on a tout à
gagner à descendre à descendre pendant
la période antique a travaillé sur
cannes et financièrement c'est plutôt
avantageux puisqu'il fait deux à trois
fois plus de chiffre d'affaires qu'à
paris s'il travaille pour hubert et
chauffeurs privés david aime faire est
aussi le patron de sa propre entreprise
en fin de journée après quelques années
dans la vente et des études d'ingénieur
du son au troisième set rap face à la
précarité du milieu d'intermittents du
spectacle
david décide de se reconvertir et de
créer sa propre société
quand j'étais en période de
de chômage j'ai fait j'ai eu des
expériences en tant que chauffeur pour
des événements comme comme roland garros
et les masters de bercy et donc qui
m'ont qui m'ont donné envie de ne pas
faire ça uniquement en intérim pour des
cons des événements ponctuels mais de
faire ça en permanence et donc j'ai créé
ma société à partir de là j'ai lancé la
création de la société et david s'est
investi à 100% dans la création de sa
société transporte 6500 euros pour
l'entreprise puis 80000 euros pour
acheter sa berline blackbirds aînés mi
décembre 2014 et david ne regrette pas
son choix
ça se passe très bien je pensais que ça
allait être plus répétitifs ou plus mais
en fait non c'est c'est très intéressant
humainement de rencontrer beaucoup de
monde
après bon moi j'aime beaucoup conduire
donc ça facilite aussi les choses j'aime
beaucoup le service à la personne donc
le mélange des trois fait que que c'est
un métier qui me plaît énormément et qui
se passe pour l'instant très bien sur
les six premiers mois en tout cas c'est
que du bonheur de se lever le matin pour
aller travailler
david est au volant d'une voiture
écologique une voiture électrique de la
marque tesla
si l'investissement a été conséquent à
l'achat le véhicule s'avère rentable sur
le long terme puisque un chauffeur roule
en moyenne 70 mille kilomètres par an la
seule contrainte trouver des bandes pour
se recharger pendant le festival david
est obligé d'aller jusqu'à fréjus à 45e
minute de cannes pour recharger sa
voiture mais avantage tout de même c'est
gratuit entre 20 et 45 minutes
on recharge suffisamment de batteries
pour atteindre un prochain super charger
et donc faire en faisant des sauts de
puce voyager gratuitement à travers
l'europe
et sinon en région parisienne on peut se
brancher sur toutes les bornes autolib
on peut se brancher sur des chargeurs
nissan dans les parkings dans l'est
centres commerciaux il ya souvent
maintenant des chargeurs qui sont à par
autolib en règle générale tous gratuits
pour l'instant l'entreprise de david ne
dispose que d'une seule voiture mais ils
envisagent d'en acquérir une deuxième
dans l'optique de proposer des offres de
transport sur mesure à sa clientèle